what up space fam golden here from anime
uproar and today i'm very excited to
talk about the backstories of all of the
hokage
i already did a video describing the
role of the hokage and each hokage's
powers
so feel free to check that out if you're
interested in that i'll link it in the
description
but here i'll be focusing on their
actual lives rather than on their powers
i made a similar video for all the yonko
in one piece and i really enjoyed that
too
i loved seeing how legendary characters
came to be what their roots were
i always find these backstories
interesting and inspiring
and i hope you will too if you do enjoy
these naruto videos and want to keep
them coming the best you could do is
smash
that like button until it changes colors
if we can get 6 000 likes on this video
i will get started on the next naruto
video asap
then after the like button has changed
colors you can leave a suggestion for me
in the comments for what naruto video
you would like to see next
if you haven't be sure to subscribe and
this is crucial hit that notification
bell and select all or you will miss
future naruto videos and while you wait
for your dream topic to get covered
feel free to check out my growing naruto
playlist which includes videos on all
the uzumaki
all the otsutsuki all the kage and much
more link to that is in the description
now without further ado let's jump into
it spoilers and all
first of all we have hashirama senju the
very first hokage and the man who was
referred to as the god of shinobi
hashiram was born to bhutsuma of the
senju clan during the warring states
period the warring states period came
before the formation of the hidden
villages
and was characterized by war and
violence hashirama was the eldest of
four brothers
during this period the extremely
powerful senju and uchiha clans were
constantly waging war against each other
and a young hashirama
and his brothers participated in these
battles when kid hashirama wasn't
fighting in wars he would sometimes skip
stones across a river
during one of these downtime moments he
met a kid around his age
from the get-go hashirama was more
talented than this kid which was evident
in his superior stone skipping skills
the kid was irritated that hashirama his
stone skipping rival
was ahead of him the two would go on to
become friends and then deadly rivals
but this dynamic between talented
hashirama senju
and the frustrated madarao chiha would
remain largely
unchanged the two kids didn't give their
family names to each other and so they
could be friends without allowing their
warring clans to get in the way
at least for the time being hashirama
had quite the sense of humor
once when he was bragging about being
better at skipping stones than madara an
irritated mother asked hashirama
if he wanted madra to skip him instead
of a stone after apologizing kid
hashirama with a grin
said he just hopes he reaches the
opposite shore
clearly poking fun at madras inability
to skip stones all the way to the other
side
i laugh out loud every time i read this
part and i really like seeing these
legendary figures
having fun and making jokes it was not
long until their idyllic
childhood friendship was interrupted by
a shinobi body floating down the river
hashirama ran
on top of the water and seeing that the
body was wearing a hagaromo
clan crest he cut the meeting short
before he left though madra offered only
his first name too
stating that not preferring one's family
name to a stranger is shinobi law
thus they both now knew that the other
was a shinobi too later hashirama's
little brother died at only 7 years old
during a battle against uchiha
and hagoromo clans his other little
brother itama
was crying and their father told them
and i quote if you're a shinobi
do not grieve shinobi are born into this
world to fight and die in battle end
quote that gives you a sense of what
hashirama's father was like
hashirama even from this young age hated
the killing and conflict and asked how
long these conflicts were going to last
and his father responded until the very
last foe has been vanquished
hashirama was not satisfied and asked if
children had to be sacrificed
his father got very mad at this point
and punched him in the face
the father felt like hashirama was
disrespecting his fallen brother by
calling him a kid
and insisted that he fought and died as
a full-fledged shinobi
so that gives you a sense of the kind of
times they were living in
seven-year-olds weren't allowed the
luxury of being thought of as children
and for even questioning the constant
conflicts you could get a knuckle
sandwich
right to the face hashirama even as a
kid was quite the critical thinker and
visionary
he realized that the fact that the senju
were called the clan of love was a joke
at this point the adults ganged up on
the kids and drove them to die in battle
there was so much fighting and death
that he said he couldn't even keep track
of all the grudges anymore he proclaimed
to his father that this shinobi world is
totally messed up
toby rama helped calm the father and son
down
but you can already see hashirama's
philosophy taking root at this
age he didn't create a perfect world but
he would definitely go on to pave the
way for a less messed up one
during the era of warring states the
average life expectancy of both shinobi
and citizens was only about 30 years
and we're told what kept it so low was
the death of many young
children itama another younger brother
of hashirama would go on to die in
battle as well
hashirama went to the river to grieve
because all the haziness of his heart
would get washed away as he stared at
the water
madara saw him there and they bonded
over the fact that they
both lost brothers in battle mother
understood that since their shinobi they
never knew when they might die
at this point madara already felt like
neither side
having to die was an impossibility but
he reveals that he's
always putting out a wish when he's here
that there is a peaceful way
where both sides revealed their bellies
and hid nothing from each other
and poured each other drinks and drank
together like brothers
hashirama was glad to find the kindred
spirit in madara
another foolish kid who thought of
changing this war-torn era
at this point hashirama considered
madara a gift from the divine
hashirama and madhara kept meeting up
from time to time and they began
sparring comparing their shinobi moves
and even talking about the future
interestingly enough they would get
draws at this point as they thought
about their vision for the future
madara told hashirama that the first
steps are to not give up on their ideals
and to get a lot stronger because weak
pups barking
won't change a thing this is a great
quote by madara and hashirama agreed
saying that if they mastered all sorts
of jutsu and got stronger the adults
wouldn't be able to ignore them
hashirama and madra grew closer to each
other every time they met up
during one meeting where hashirama beat
madara in a race to the top of the cliff
by cheating and starting first madra
almost revealed that he had the shutting
gun
and then went on to say that he only had
one brother left out of four
he promised that he would protect this
younger brother no matter what hashirama
spoke of building a settlement where
they were
where kids wouldn't have to kill each
other he dreamed of schools where kids
could train of missions
fit to an individual's abilities but the
recurring pattern here is that he wanted
a place where kids didn't have to be
sent into deadly battlefields
although madra called this dream
nonsense at first he did admit that in
such a place
he could watch over and protect his
little brother and the two smiled
together
and sure enough that was the place where
konoha would eventually stand and on
that day
hashirama made a resolution to endure
for the sake of his vision
the fox and the hound-like relationship
couldn't continue for long though
because hashirama's father confronted
his son and told him that the kid he was
meeting up with was part of the jihad
clan their mortal enemies
his father called madra a shinobi genius
who has taken down adults of their clan
hashirama actually figured as much and
was notably not too surprised by his
father's words this friendship that they
had formed was now
unraveling as hashirama's father was
telling him to spy on his friend
to bring intel about the uchiha and to
kill madara if he gets suspicious
and so once again the adult world
encroaches on the kids one fateful day
toby rama
and father sendru follow hashirama when
he goes to meet madara the two skip
stones to each other
and on those stones they've let each
other know that a trap is being set up
for them
by their rival clans as both make
excuses for leaving their families have
different plans and confront each other
we got hashirama's dad and only
remaining younger brother versus
madara's dad
and only remaining younger brother
hashirama's dad butsuma
and madara's dad tajima knew from many
past encounters that they had about
equal strength so it came down to the
little brothers tobi rama and izuna as
we're told shinobi are trained to keep
their hearts in check
on the battlefield no matter what
happens since a single flash of
emotional disarray can lead to
vulnerability and mean the difference
between life and death and the two
fathers knew
if they saw their own child killed it
would unbalance
their heart and probably ensure the
opponent's victory hashirama and madara
begged them to stop
fighting but the hatred and animosity
between the clans was too strong
and they paid no attention to their
pleas the fathers tried to kill each
other's youngest living sons but
hashirama and madhara used the stones in
their hands to repel the attacks
finally madara getting defensive over
his brother says that maybe their pipe
dream of a peaceful ninja community
just isn't possible madhara lets his
father know that hashirama is stronger
than him
and so do chiha's retreat because
hashirama is a senju and madara lost his
brothers to sendru he says their next
meeting will be on the battlefield
this is a truly powerful and sad moment
where the kids can no longer
avoid being corrupted by the adult world
at this point mother fully awakened his
shotting on eye
because he decided to completely erase
his friendship with hashirama hashirama
and madara would go on to fight each
other many times and each became the
leader of their respective clans
hashirama though had never abandoned
their dream and in one instance
after flexing the fact that madara
couldn't beat him he suggested they end
the fighting the senju and uchiha were
considered the strongest shinobi clans
so if they joined forces
eventually nations would not be able to
find other clans that could stand
against them
and the conflict would die down madra
was listening but his little brother
who was wounded by toby rama told him
not to be deceived and so mother left
the battlefield at this point do chihan
knew
they were in an unfavorable position and
there were defectors who joined forces
with the senju who knows what might have
happened if madara's sole surviving
brother lived but he didn't he died from
the wounds
mother obtained the eternal mangekyo
shotting gun
which he planned to use to help protect
uchiha hashirama
kept talking about ceasefire agreements
and ending the fighting but madara
wanted to fight thinking peace was
impossible they battled for a whole day
and hashirama again came out on top
toby rama was ready to kill madara but
hashirama stopped him and forbade anyone
to touch him mother was pretty
understanding of the situation and even
said it would be okay to die
by hashirama's hand it would be an honor
in fact hashirama's goal was always
peace and so he asked if they could skip
stones again like in olden times
madara though couldn't agree to this
since he lost all his brothers and
couldn't trust hashirama
however he said that one way to show
each other their guts was for hashirama
to kill his brother
or himself to make it even at that point
madara would be willing to trust the
senju clan
i gotta say i'd probably respond more
like toby rama in this situation who
said
that mother is crazy and hashirama
shouldn't listen to him but hashirama
was an idealist who was always willing
to sacrifice his life for peace
and so it wasn't that shocking when he
decided to take his own life he told
toby rama to make sure that though jihad
and sanju
never fight again hashirama was arguably
too much of an idealist and for him to
just
trust that madra and toby rama would get
along after his death was pretty
unrealistic but still
his trust in madara was rewarded and
madara ended up stopping hashirama's
kunai
to madara's credit he said he'd seen
enough he'd seen hashirama's guts
and they came to an agreement the dream
was realized sendru and uchiha came
together to build a village
where hopefully no more children would
have to be sacrificed they joined hands
with the fire country to create a
peaceful nation that considered the
country and the village to be on the
same level
it was during this hopeful period that
hashirama told madara about the idea of
the hokage aka
fire shadow the head of shinobi who
would protect the country of fire from
the shadows
it was the fire country that asked them
to decide on the head of the village and
hashirama wanted madara to become
konoha's first hokage even though he
didn't have any more brothers
hashirama hoped that he could consider
all the ninja in the village to be his
family
at this point the sarutobi clan and
shimura clan
also wanted to become allies with the
senju and uchiha clans
everything seemed to be coming together
believe it or not during this
conversation it was madara who looking
at the village through a hole in a leaf
came up with the name of konoha the
village hidden behind the leaf
during these conversations hashirama and
madhara thought over exactly what the
hokage would do
like staying in the village to watch
over it and hashirama came up with the
idea of carving madara's face into the
big stone
to symbolize how he'd protect the
village so we have hashirama to thank
for hokage
mount rushmore even as things looked
hopeful it was obvious that there were
tensions like between toby rama and
madara tobi rama told hashirama that he
couldn't decide
who would be hokkage by himself and that
madara would never be chosen by the
seniors
according to tobi rama even though chiha
acknowledged hashirama as the true
founder of the village
tobirama also told hashirama that the
shaningan becomes more powerful through
hatred
so you never know what do chiha might do
hashirama hated this discriminating talk
and put a stop to it but he was too late
and the leaf on the ground
outside of the window implied that
madara had overheard toby rama's words
when toby rama said the village would be
a democracy hashirama agreed
and it was his face that was carved into
the big stone instead of mataras
as hokage hashirama kept trying to get
madra on board
and said he would be the second hokage
but madara knew that that title would go
to tobirama
you see here how hashirama's idealism
could make the situation worse
he spoke before he thought things
through and got madara's hopes up
only for them to be crushed later after
he pretty much told mother he'd be
hokage you can understand why madara
would be upset when hashirama became the
first hokage
on top of that he knew toby rama and
others like tobi rama didn't
like or at least didn't trust madara and
uchiha and they were likely the future
leaders of konoha if toby rama were to
take over
madara felt like the uchiha were going
to be exterminated
so the pessimistic madara had plenty of
valid reasons to question hashirama's
optimism but when he told his people to
leave the village
not even one uchiha listened to him at
this point madara's life was falling
apart
he felt like he couldn't protect his
clan just like he couldn't protect his
brothers
his own clan didn't trust him anymore
and that went double for the senju while
hashirama kept wanting him to be hopeful
for the future and to give it time
madara came to the conclusion that he
should have ordered toby rama's death
that time he gave hashirama the option
to take his own life even though
hashirama called mother his brother
madara knew that if hashirama had to
sacrifice toby rama or madara himself
for the village
hashirama would choose to sacrifice
madara hashirama's silence seemed to
prove madara's point
so he left the village and decided to
continue his fight against hashirama in
the village that seemingly betrayed him
it wasn't all bad news for hashirama
though even though he lost a friend the
rest of the world praised and
imitated their village system inspired
by the fact that past rivals of chiha
and senju joined forces from hashirama's
perspective his and madara's childhood
dream had come true
kids didn't have to fight their life
expectancy went up and they had time to
learn and play
nevertheless madara kept trying to
destroy his previous dream he kept on
attacking konoha and hashirama kept
beating him mada even tried to use a
susano covered nine tails to defeat
hashirama
and it still didn't work showing just
how insanely powerful the god of shinobi
was
during their final battle hashirama
stabbed madara in the back with a sword
and promised to take care of their
village as he was putting an
end to their constant fighting hashirama
told his childhood friend that and i
quote
anyone who tries to harm the village
whether they're his friends
siblings or even his children he won't
forgive them and so
that was the end hashirama had changed
he was no longer the man who would
continue to give madara a chance after
chance to change
hashirama's dream did bring about many
benefits but as he later acknowledged
the village wasn't perfect
and it did eventually create the
darkness that people like hitachi had to
shoulder
a darkness that madara arguably foresaw
in hashirama's view
a shinobi is one who endures to achieve
his goals
and hashirama did exactly that yeah he
didn't achieve lasting peace
but he did the best he could he would go
on to have the nine tails sealed inside
his wife mito uzumaki
in so doing he secured that great power
for konoha
after madara's defeat things were more
peaceful hashirama had children and
notably a granddaughter called tsunade
who would go on to become the fifth
hokage the god of shinobi remarked and
was amused by the fact that
she inherited his love of gambling
during this time of peace
hashirama also sealed away the secret
manuscript that naruto goes on to steal
during the first chapter of the story
because of how dangerous the techniques
within were and because they were no
longer needed
in this safer world he had brought into
fruition safer doesn't mean completely
safe though and conflict didn't
disappear
at one point takigakure the village
hidden in the waterfall
would send futurakatsuki member kakuzu
to assassinate hashirama
hashirama defeated kakuzu but wars
continued hashirama ever the man wanting
peace
staged a gokage summit where he shared
tailed beasts he had caught with other
kage of the five great nations in an
attempt to balance out the power
and ensure peace he was even willing to
give them away for free but toby rama
told him to shut it and that konoha was
selling them at a price
it's funny even though hashirama was
physically stronger
tobirama seemed to be the one more
talented in affairs of the state
and he would usually tell his older
brother how it had to be done
this first gokage summit led to the end
of minor conflict
even at this first summit there was
plenty of arguing and even hashirama
didn't know how long the peace treaty
would last
but he had a dream that a day would come
when shinobi collaborate and help each
other with one heart regardless of their
affiliation
he considered this treaty the first step
toward that dream
and begged the other kage to take that
step with him
and sure enough that day does come when
five kage have to rally around
a greater enemy but even though
hashirama didn't achieve what he wanted
in his lifetime i really liked the way
that he continued to work in the present
in an attempt to create a better future
for later generations
just because you may not live long
enough to see a tree at its prime
doesn't mean that planting it today has
no value when hashirama died
he passed on the title of hokage to his
advisor and brother toby rama and told
him over and over again
not to mistreat though jihad
unfortunately we haven't gotten any
satisfying explanation for how such a
strong shinobi died
when konoha was just beginning to
flourish it was during an unspecified
conflict but perhaps one day kishimoto
will give us the full story now the
first hokage's backstory was especially
long because his is arguably the most
important one
since it contains the formation of the
village and the creation of the title of
hokage itself so i'll try to keep the
rest shorter especially because much of
toby rama's backstory was already
contained within his brother's backstory
as mentioned even from a young age
tobirama supported hashirama's idea of a
new system
that would get rid of wars through
signed pact even if toby rama was less
idealistic about it than his older
brother
on one occasion tobirama followed his
father's orders and found out that his
brother was secretly meeting with an
ochiha and he participated in the
already mentioned fight between the
families
before hashirama and madara managed a
temporary ceasefire in one of their
future fights toby rama managed to
morally wound izunau chiha
madara's only surviving brother in a
future battle where hashirama decisively
defeated madara tobirama wanted to
finish him but hashirama stopped him
this was when madara gave him the
ultimatum kill your brother or yourself
and toby rama called him crazy which
makes sense
why agree to such a ridiculous request
from your utterly defeated opponent
anyways hashirama didn't choose to take
his brother's life but his own before
madara stopped him and agreed to work
together they found konoha a place where
kids can play and learn
and don't have to die in battle tobiram
was around the whole time
as hashirama's practical advisor
tempering hashirama's unbridled optimism
he pointed out that hashirama couldn't
decide that madara would be hokkage on
his own
and that in this democracy the people
would have to decide
who the first leader of the village
would be just as tobirama expected the
people elected hashirama to be the first
hokage
as mentioned toby rama was the one who
ensured that the other villagers
actually paid for their op
tailed beasts whereas hashirama just
wanted to give them away for free
tobi rama trained and led a three-man
team that included a young hirozan
sarutobi who would go on to become the
third hokage he was also a genius when
it came to creating techniques
he created many famous ones including
the shadow clone technique and more
infamously the edo tensei aka the impure
world reincarnation technique
that orochimaru would go on to improve
upon after hashirama defeated madhara
the final time at the valley of the end
tobirama studied the corpse and the
mysteries of the shutting gun but rather
than destroying madara's body
he hid it deep within konoha's mountains
after hashirama died in an
unspecified conflict tobirama inherited
the title of the second hokage
and the command not to mistreat thou
shiha tobirama after all was always less
trusting of the uchiha clan because of
the potential threat they posed to the
village
and although it's widely thought that he
hated uchiha
tobirama defends himself by saying he
simply treated any who posed
a danger to the village no matter what
clan they belonged to with extreme
caution
however he did respect some uchiha like
kagami who put the village
above their clan which is what he wanted
from everyone tobirama didn't just come
up with amazing jutsus he's also to
thank for the academy the anbu
and the tuning exams all of which are
integral parts of the village by the
time the naruto series begins
additionally it was toby rama's idea for
uchiha to run the konoha military police
force
some like orochimaru would go so far as
to say that the rebellious uchihaku
was at least in part the result of the
creation of the police force
as orochimaru explains and i quote those
who crack down on crime tend to be
easily disliked
plus the more authority such a group has
the more conceited it can get
end quote orochimaru added that by
building the police station where he did
and shoving to chihak clan to the
margins of the village
tobi rama helped foster madara-like
sentiments
once again toby ram would defend himself
by saying that tu chiha were eminently
qualified for that position
on the one hand you could argue that it
was toby rama's way of honoring and
showing his trust in dochiha
after all you don't put those you don't
trust in charge of enforcing the law on
the other hand like arochimaru pointed
out you could argue at marginalized
uchiha
and set them apart from everyone else
which inevitably hurt
the quote unquote village before the
clan end goal
like hashirama tobi rama worked on
alliances and even attended a ceremony
to cement the alliance between konoha
and kumo gakurei unfortunately the gold
and silver brothers known as the worst
criminals in all of kumo history
staged a coup attacking both toby rama
and the second raikkog
we're told they wielded the five
treasured tools of the sage of six paths
and drove toby rama
to the brink of death toby rama survived
this but it would not be the last time
he had trouble with kumo gakura ninja
they really seem to be his kryptonite
which seems kind of fitting if you think
about how he specializes in water style
jutsu while kumo
and ninja are associated with lightning
like the rai kage now to be clear i'm
speaking symbolically because toby rama
could actually use all nature
transformations and he could definitely
defeat the vast majority of lightning
style users
but that doesn't change the fact that
the gold and silver brothers from kumo
almost killed him once and kumo ninja
would be the ones to finish him off too
during the first shinobi war toby rama
and his escort unit
which included sarutobi danzo
kagamiuchiha and three others was
surrounded by 20
highly skilled enemy ninja it was the
kinkaku unit
the group decided someone would have to
act as the sacrificial lure
and draw the enemy away so the others
could escape
as donzo was trembling and trying to
talk himself into volunteering
sarutobi beat him to it however toby
rama decided he himself would be the
distraction
before he left he told danzo to set
aside his rivalry with saratobi it was
time for them to unite
and work as comrades he passed on the
role of hokage to sarutobi and told him
to love the village to protect those who
believe in him and to develop those who
would be able to protect the next
era we don't see the final battle which
kind of sucks
but it is implied that the 20 highly
skilled cloud ninja were simply too much
for him to handle
some unofficial sources state that he
was specifically killed by king kaku
of the gold and silver brothers but i
couldn't find any satisfying proof of
this
it's true that during chapter 529
shikamaru states that kinkaku messed up
the second hokage but that is likely
referring to the aforementioned coup
where toby rama was brought to the brink
of death however
if i'm overlooking any relevant canon
material feel free to let me know and
link it in the comments
the specifics of his death aside it's
clear that toby rama brought a lot of
value to konoha
whether it was as a pragmatic advisor to
his brother as hokage himself as
a creator of a shocking amount of
amazing jutsu or as the creator of
famous institutions like the academy
there is no doubt a dark side as well to
his legacy as some blame him for the
fate of do chiha and some of his
techniques would later be used against
the village
like when arochimaru used arotensei to
attack konoha
nevertheless tobii rama played a huge
role in shaping what konoha became
arguably the biggest out of any hokage
and it is not an understatement to say
that the konoha of naruto's time would
look completely different
perhaps even be unrecognizable if not
for tobirama's influence
to get a sense of his influence just
take a second to try and imagine naruto
without shadow clones or without the
academy
or without the tuning exams i could go
on but i think you get the idea
now on to the third hokage the man who
is hokage when the story begins hirozen
sarutobi
hirozen stands out even among hokage and
has been hailed as a shinobi god just
like hashirama interestingly enough
his father was named sasuke sarutobi and
sasuke uchiha's mother gave him that
name
hoping he'd also grow up to be a strong
splendid shinobi
both tobirama and even hashirama spent
time teaching the talented hirose
through tobii rama's backstory we
figured out that saratobi was special
even compared to the title to donzo who
was jealous of sarutobi and viewed him
as a rival
not only was sarutobi the first to offer
to be the lure
during the first shinobi world war he
also noted that he was the most
accomplished of the bunch which is
significant because this bunch was the
second hokage's elite team
given his talent and his willingness to
sacrifice himself for his team
it is not surprising that toby rama
picked hirozen to be the third hokage
hirozan went on to marry biwako sarutobi
and together they had a son
and named him asuma osuma would go on to
become the charismatic leader of team 10
and play shogi with shikamaru asuma also
had
at least one other sibling who joined
the on boo and gave hirozen a grandson
in the form of konohamaru hirosen served
as the team leader of the sunning
and even conducted the bell's test with
oroshimaru to nade and jarya when they
were still young
although jiraiya complained that hirozen
would always compliment orochimaru over
him
hirozen a perv in his own right was
interested in joining jiraiya when he
went researching hirozen was close to
his students and was even there to
comfort the orphaned orochimaru when he
visited the grave of his parents
hirozan would go on to lead konoha
through the second and third great ninja
wars
the anime focused more on the
relationship between him and donzo where
hirosen permitted donso to create root
or the foundation
a darker more secret and more merciless
branch of the anbu hiroshima overlooked
donzo's immoral actions
even when they were targeted at the
hokage himself after deciding to end the
third great war
by agreeing on a not so favorable peace
with the village hidden the stones
hirosen was pressured to take
responsibility for his actions by donzo
and he did so by stepping down and
having the fourth hokage
installed throughout hirozon's backstory
you can see the recurring idea of his
softness
as donzo calls it although he's strong
he's too forgiving to the detriment of
the village and himself despite his
initial hopes for his pupil
rochimaru he knew that he couldn't
select him to be the fourth hokage
because of his warped thinking so he
chose jiraiya's disciple minato namikaze
who had proved himself worthy during the
third great war
of course hirozan continued to assist
the village and advised minato
when he needed help hirozan continued to
have andu assigned to him and when it
came time for minato's wife and the
nine-tails jinchuriki kushner zumaki to
give birth to naruto it was hirozen who
let them know that she'd give birth
inside a barrier away from the village
and that his anbu would serve as her
guards notably hirozen's wife biwako
accompanied kushina watched over her and
advised her during this period
despite their efforts thanks to obito
the nine tails ended up in the village
and hirozen prepared to restrain the
nine tails while telling the anbu to
protect the civilians
hirozen and the ninja of the village
succeed in driving the nine tails out of
the village as mirato fights obito
eventually minato joins them and
teleports the nine tails away as hirosen
watches from the sidelines
all he can do is watch because kushner
has erected a barrier which keeps the
nine tails from escaping but also the
third from coming in minato and kushna
sacrificed their lives
and make their son the next gen church
of the ninetales in order to save the
village
we were told by hirozen as early as the
second chapter
that the fourth wanted naruto to be
regarded as the savior of the village
and a hero since he was sacrificed in a
sense for the safety of the village
however hirosen points out that people
didn't choose to see it that way
they viewed the jinshuriki child with
hatred hostility
and even wished to deny his right to
exist so what could hirosen do
he decided to suppress as much
information about the ninetales as
possible
creating severe laws and penalties for
any who disclosed the secret
naruto was also given his mother's last
name so that naruto
wouldn't be targeted as the fourth son
by enemies
as we know hirozen's approach didn't
really change the way people treated
naruto he was still an
outcast and some naruto fans continued
to believe that hirozen could have done
more to help change the public's view of
naruto moving on it turned out that
hirozan was right to trust his feelings
about orochimaru because during one
occasion it was discovered that
orochimaru was kidnapping ninja
including genning
tuning and even on boo to experiment on
orochimaru revealed to hirozen that in
part he was experimenting with the art
of immortality a forbidden jutsu
that can keep one's mind and soul
anchored in this world for eternity
hiroshima
acknowledged that it was his indulgences
that brought about this situation
and the following one where orochimaru
attacked the village a good deal after
during this instance where he was
confronting orochimaru about the
experiments he admitted that he couldn't
bring himself to kill his student
and he let him get away a move that
would end up hurting konoha
and sealing the third's own fate one of
orochimaru's discovered experiments was
yamato aka tenzo orochimaru had inserted
hashirama cells into 60 children
and most didn't make it but yamato did
and gained the ability to use the first
hokage's wood style
he would go on to become an exemplary
shinobi even among the on bu
during the third's rule and beyond after
the nine tails attack
people started to suspect that it might
have been the fault of the uchiha clan
because of the shoting gun's ability to
control the ninetails
do chiha in turn were insulted and
planned a coup itachi let the third and
his konoha council know about the
planned attack
donzo wanted to strike with a surprise
attack first but hiroson considered doo
chiha his old comrades in
arms and wanted to try to use words
before violence
danzo without hirosen's approval helped
to convince hitachi to eliminate du
chiha by presenting it as a way to avoid
civil war
and save his little brother sasuke after
the uchiha clan was wiped out hirozan
finally told donso that he can't allow
him to act on his own authority anymore
and formally dissolved his root
organization
hirosa knew the truth about why tachi
did what he did so when itashi showed up
and
asked him to protect sasuke against
donzo and the councilors
the third agreed and even said that
hitachi could sneak into the village and
check on sasuke whenever he was worried
about him and although hiro's
story continues that is it for the
backstory portion like the second hokage
there are definitely reasons you could
criticize the third he gave donzo too
many chances
he gave orochimaru too many chances and
he arguably didn't do a good job of
watching over naruto
and making sure that he wasn't treated
as an outcast however he had good
intentions and he was ready to
and did sacrifice himself for the
village when the time came for him to do
so although the first three hokage were
legendary fighters and did a lot of good
taking a look at their backstories
reveals that they were still far from
perfect we've also seen that being a
hokage is a much harder job than you may
have expected at first glance
and there is much more to it than just
beating up strong bad guys
next we have naruto's dad himself
injuria's pupil mina tona mikaze aka the
fourth hokage
minato was lucky in the sense that
during his rule he could rely on the
third whenever he needed to
minato has been called the yellow flash
because of his insane speed and jiraya
even thought that minato might be the
child of prophecy who would emerge as a
savior of the world
although this ended up being a better
description of mirato's son naruto
minato did end up being the savior of
konoha and the savior of the savior of
the world
when he saved naruto from obito and the
nine tails
but let's go back to the beginning of
his story minato met his future wife
kushina at the academy when they were
both little kids
she had just transferred to konoha the
first day she came
they had to tell the class what they
wanted to be when they grew up and
kushna actually yelled out that she was
going to be the first female hokage this
is even crazier than kid naruto doing
the same thing because keep in mind
she had just transferred to the village
and she was already saying that she'd be
hokage
the other kids thought she was snotty
and so they called the round-faced
and red-haired girl tomato she would
then get angry and beat them up and then
her nickname evolved to the red hot
habanero when it came to minato
he said he wanted to become a great
hokage and he wanted everyone in the
village to respect him his hokage rival
kushina
mocked him and looked down on him
thinking he was too girly and
undependable
until a certain incident years later
kumo gakurei kidnapped
kushina because of her special chakra
all she could do was leave strands of
her hair along the way
minato was the only one who noticed her
red hair and rescued her he told her
that he noticed her hair immediately
because it was so pretty
after that day kushina stopped hating
the color of her hair
and realized that minato would be a
great ninja keep in mind minato was
still pretty young and he beat
multiple adult ninja who had a hostage
not too shabby kushina began to view her
red hair as the thing that brought her
her love
she fell in love with her savior minato
as mentioned minato was part of team
jaraya and jiraiya saw his student as a
rare genius
according to jaraya mineto was kind and
gentle yet fierce and full of grit
he became the fourth hokage in the blink
of an eye which seems fitting for
konoha's yellow flash
donzo even tried to say he was too young
for the job
anyways after minato rescued kushina
they became a couple with the help of
his love
kushner was able to live and even enjoy
her life as a nine-tailed jin churiki
as you may well know during his life
minato created the rasengan
after observing a tailed beast ball it
took him three years
and his plan was to combine it with his
own nature but he didn't succeed before
his death
what's crazy to think about is that
naruto was able to learn the rasengan in
like a month if we include all of
jorah's different training stages
and eventually succeeded in combining
his nature with the rasan gun to create
the wind release rasengan
and then the s-ranked win release rasen
shuriken so if minato is a rare genius
what does that make his son
obviously it is easier to learn
something when someone is teaching you
than just coming up with the idea on
your own but still you can't deny
naruto's impressive feats and i like how
he perfected what his father
started just as minato was in team
jarayak he eventually led team minato
which consisted of kakashi hatake
obito
was a star in the third great war and
his performance would eventually secure
his position
as the fourth hokage in one instance
during the third grade war minato took
down
one thousand iwagakure shinobi on his
own
despite how impressive minato was though
he couldn't be everywhere at once
he wasn't there when obito went down but
he did manage to come in time to save
kakashi and rin
however rin was later kidnapped and
forcefully turned
into the three tails jinchuriki and then
decided to die by kakashi's hand
rather than enter konoha as a trojan
horse this was yet another instance
where minato wasn't present to protect
his students
and so only kakashi remained during the
third war mina toranta a
who'd eventually become the fourth
rykage on the battlefield along with b
minotau was faster and interestingly
enough he already knew that they'd both
become
kage one day despite the fact that they
were on opposing sides there was clearly
respect between these two
legendary ninja minotaur went on to
become the fourth hokage
being chosen over orochimaru kushina
became pregnant and they decided to name
the child naruto after the main
character in jiraiya's first book
and thus they honored minato's sensei
and also made jiraiya
naruto's godfather and when you know
that the earlier parts of the series
when naruto and jorah first meet and
train together
hit different so let's look at october
10th the night naruto
was born obito used the newborn naruto
as a hostage
and used him to separate minato from his
jinchuriki wife while minato was busy
saving his newborn son from exploding
tags
obito extracted the ninetales from
kushina taking advantage of the fact
that the nine-tailed seal was weakened
due to childbirth
obito was impressed to see that kushina
as an uzumaki was able to survive the
extraction
he was about to let the ninetales finish
her off but minotau came in a flash
and took her to safety where naruto was
she hugged her baby
as minotau went to take care of hokage
business
obito took control of the nine tails and
released it in the village
minato appeared and teleported a biju
ball away in order to save hokage mount
rushmore while the third and the others
turned their attention to the ninetails
obito confronted minato these two
teleporters fought and minato did
extremely well
even though minato remarked that obito's
teleportation ninjutsu surpassed both
his own and the second hokages
he nevertheless managed to hit obito
without a sengon
and to release the nine tails from his
control after praising minato obito
retreated but not before adding like a
true villain that he'd ruled the world
someday
with one win under his belt minato
turned to the nine tails
with gamabunta's help the fourth managed
to teleport the nine tails to a safe
distance
although it cost him so much chakra that
kushina had to be the one to erect a
barrier around them
kushner was prepared to take the nine
tails with her to her death but minato
didn't want that
since kushina wanted to see naruto grown
up he took the rest of her chakra and
sealed it inside naruto so they could
speak someday
then he decided he'd use the reaper
death seal and seal half of the nine
tails in himself and the other half in
naruto
kushna argued with minato wondering why
minato had to die
why naruto had to become a jinchuriki
but minato saw this as the best option
since it would let kushinas see grown up
naruto and help the village since the
bijou balance
wouldn't be upset and hopefully naruto
would be able to use the ninetails one
day to stop obito
and to protect the village although they
were both going to die for naruto
anyways
minoto and kushina also used their
bodies to protect their newborn child
from kurama's deadly claw
before minato sealed kurama a part of
kushna in a part of himself into naruto
kushina spoke with her child telling him
among other things to make a few friends
he can trust
to not get depressed if things don't go
well because everyone is good at some
things and not so good at others to make
sure he has dreams and the confidence to
make those dreams come true
and of course she tells him that she
loves him and minato not having much
time left simply smiles and says ditto
and he seals their remaining chakra
inside the newborn naruto and although
naruto admits later that he went through
a lot
as a jin shuriki kid with no parents
he's happy when he hears about this
backstory from his mother
because he realizes that they always
loved him it's a moment that brings
kushner to
tears naruto to tears and yes even me to
tears
but for now let's wipe those tears away
and move on to the fifth hokage's
backstory
tsunade like jirai and orochimaru was
one of konohassanin aka one of the
legendary
three ninja she is the granddaughter of
the first hokage hashirama and of the
first nine-tailed jin churuki mito
uzumaki
and thus contains both senju and uzumaki
dna
quite the op genes in this one in life
she earned a title not only of hokage
but also of strongest female ninja
and best medical ninja but as usual
let's rewind things a bit
as mentioned tsunade was hashirama's
first ever granddaughter so he spoiled
her rotten
to use his own words the first hokage
also was very amused by the fact that
she picked up his gambling habit
tsunade inherited his necklace as well
as mentioned after the academy tsunade
teamed up with aroshimaru and jiraiya
they were led by hirozen sarutobi
himself from their first meeting jiraiya
flirted with tsunade telling her she
could send her love letters to him later
and although he teased her before
calling her a tomboy and flat-chested
tsunade did develop as the jiraya's
interest in her he clearly liked her
enough to research her while she was
bathing and that led to tunade beating
him up badly
according to jaraya he was close to
death he got six broken ribs
broke both his arms and had several
ruptured organs
there were two figures in tunade's
backstory who stood
above the rest in importance her little
brother nawaki
and her lover dan they both wanted to
become hokage
on nawaki's 12th birthday tsunade gave
him their grandfather's necklace she was
optimistic
and hoped he'd achieve his dreams
however he died the very next day after
receiving the necklace and this was
during the second great war
clearly children could still be
casualties despite hashirama's wish to
create a place
safe for children in this case his very
own grandson was a victim
tsunade now with her necklace back
realized it advocated that people like
her brother nawaki could have actually
survived or at least had a better chance
of surviving
if every four-man team had at least one
medical ninja the third liked her idea
but also felt that they couldn't make
that their priority in the middle of a
war
tsunade clearly disagreed and a ninja
named dan
took her side believing that ninjas
should learn from the past so people
don't continue to die needlessly
dan and tsunade grew closer like tsunade
dan had lost a sibling
and like the first hokage he wanted to
bring peace to this warring world
he wanted to become hokage so he could
protect the people of the village
so they wouldn't end up like his sister
during the second war
tsunade alongside jurai norochimaru
faced off against the legendary hanzo of
amegakure it was during this fight
impressed by the three and how they
survived the fierce battle that hanzo
dubbed them the sunning of konoha
additionally tsunade's medical expertise
came in handy during the war when it
came to counteracting the poisons that
chio of tsunagakure created
in fact tsunadi was so good at creating
antidotes immediately that it straight
up embarrassed chio
whose specialty was poisons but despite
contributing so much to the war effort
tsunade couldn't save
dan the seemingly cursed necklace struck
again tsunade was touched by dan's dream
and wanted him to realize it so she gave
him the first hokage's necklace
just like she gave it to her little
brother before and just like that time
dan
ended up dying on the battlefield
wearing the necklace he was injured so
badly that even though tsunade was
present she couldn't save him with her
medical ninjutsu then resisted death
saying he couldn't die before he
accomplished his dreams so tsunade
played along
suggesting that he'd be fine he died in
the rain and tsunade who had opened her
heart once more to someone after she was
hurt so badly by her brother's passing
had to suffer the same fate all over
again it was her inability to stop dan's
blood loss that led to her developing
blood phobia
she had understandably become
traumatized and pessimistic about
people's dreams
and so tsunade got her necklace back yet
again after the war she left konoha with
shizune dan's niece
she trained her and shizune ended up
becoming her apprentice
the broken tsunade retired from medicine
and combat
and spent her days gambling or more
accurately losing a gambling
she was known as the legendary sucker
because she lost
so much eventually naruto would show up
and help knock tsunadi out of her funk
but that is a topic for another video
for now let's move on to the sixth
hokage's backstory
kakashi hatake went on to inherit the
title of hokage from tsunade after the
fourth great war
we know kakashi as the copy ninja as
kakashi of the shutting gun
as the leader of team seven and of
course as the sixth hokage but let's
take a look at how this legend got
started kokashi was the son of sakumo
hatake and his mother died when he was
very young
sakumo was a powerful and famous ninja
himself renowned as konoha's white fang
minato even said that during sakumo's
time the sunning paled in comparison to
him
during an important mission sakumo
decided to put the lives of his cell
members
ahead of the mission which is a no-go in
the ninja world
as a result he was vilified and blamed
for the great deal of damage that
resulted from abandoning the mission
even the people he saved slandered him
eventually this dishonor and rejection
was too much for his body and soul to
take
and he took his own life at that point
kid kikashi
decided not to speak about his father
and to devote himself to the laws and
regulations of the village
it's a shame that the opinions of others
affected sakuramo so negatively
especially because he was a likable
character when kid kakashi was putting
down
kid might guy for failing the academy
entrance exam
and for not being able to use ninjutsu
his father warned him not to slack off
or at
mike guy's rate of training he'll become
stronger than kakashi
right away sakumo recognized might guy
as a worthy rival to his son
and hoped that they'd get along and as
kakashi later realized his father was
completely right about my guy's insane
level of potential
in the academy kakashi earned top grades
and was recognized as an elite genius
the best of his generation he graduated
from the academy in one year at the age
of five
as mentioned he was teamed up with obito
and rin under the leadership of minato
just like hirozen gave a bell test so
did minato and so would kakashi as we
well know
kakashi beat my guy during the exam and
became a tuning
at 6 years old the best way to describe
early kakashi is that he was insanely
talented and excelled on paper but he
was haunted by his father's death
and that led to him considerably
downplaying the importance of teamwork
and friendship during the third great
war kakashi had been promoted to joni
and minato left him in charge during one
mission while he went to fight on the
front lines
their goal was an infiltration mission
to destroy the enemy's supply bridge
and evacuate during this mission kakashi
used chile for the first time on the
battlefield but he ended up having to be
saved by minato who told the young
hikashi not to use it anymore
because although it has speed and
destructive power it makes him move too
fast to the point he can't ascertain
the opponent's counter-attack it would
not be a perfected jutsu until he
inherited his shotgun eye from obito the
power of which could
eliminate its vulnerability minato then
left them telling them that the one
thing important above all
else is teamwork kakashi obito and rin
went on to work on their mission
rin was kidnapped by iwagakurei shinobi
and obito wanted to go after her right
away but as usual kakashi wanted to
prioritize completing their mission
since that's what the law dictated the
two argued and kakashi told obito that
emotion was just a useless burden
obito had had enough and decided that
he'd disobey orders and go
save rin kakashi warned him about the
consequences for breaking rules
obito said that he knew them and he was
gonna go through with it anyways
and he added that that's why the white
fang aka kakashi's father
was a true hero this is an epic moment
for obito and his words stay with
kakashi
he tells kakashi and i quote those that
break the rules
and regulations are scum but those who
abandon their comrades
are worse than scum if i'm going to be
called scum either way i'd rather break
the rules and if that's not being a
proper shinobi then i'll destroy that
idea
end quote although the two walk off in
different directions
my heart does smile when kakashi
eventually comes back
and joins obito the enemies can't help
but think of the white fang of konoha
when they see kakashi's white hair
and his light blade in action while
protecting obito kakashi loses his left
eye although obito can only cry at first
for being a useless burden
he does recover and actually awakens his
shutting gun he uses his newfound power
to locate and defeat the camouflage
using ninja they managed to rescue it in
but during the escape obito saves
kakashi by hitting the ladder to safety
as he gets crushed by a falling boulder
in his stead as obito is dying kakashi
blames himself
thinking if only he came with obito from
the start none of this would have
happened
obito just smiles though saying that he
forgot to give kakashi a gift for
becoming a journey and so he offers his
shutting an eye to him
not only that obito tells kakashi that
he's a great joni
i like how obito frames this as well
saying that he'll become kakashi's eye
and they'll see what happens in the
future so even though he'll be gone
kakashi will always carry a part of him
kakashi uses his new shotgun to defeat
the remaining enemy using his perfected
chidori that he can now use to the
fullest thanks to the perceptive powers
of the shoting gun
the enemy forces keep on coming but now
kakashi can use his perfected chidori to
keep his promise to obito
and protect it in with his life kakashi
tells rin that obito loved her and that
he gave his life to protect her but she
tries to confess her own love for
kakashi only to have kakashi reveal
that he was ready to desert her
fortunately minato showed up and
defeated all the enemies before kakashi
had to sacrifice his own life too
minato then apologizes for not coming in
time to save obito we're told that two
heroes were born on that day
both of which possessed one shotting gun
one was obito who had his name engraved
on a memorial stone
and the other came to be known as
kakashi of the sharingan we're told that
tales of kakashi's bravery spanned
all borders and beyond at a later date
rin got kidnapped by kirigakurei and
forced to become the three-tailed jiniki
kakashi succeeded in getting her out of
kirigakure but that was actually their
plan
to get that in into the hidden leaf
village and then for the three tails to
attack the village
ren knew about this so when kakashi was
using his lightning blade aka lightning
cutter to fight enemy ninja
she threw herself in front of it in the
end she chose to die at the hands of
someone she loved in order to protect
konoha
as a side no kakashi's children was
renamed lightning blade because it was
said that he perfected it to the point
where he was able to split a bolt of
lightning with it
killing it in was never an option for
kakashi he had promised obito to protect
her
and he was determined to find another
way he wasn't going to lose rin like he
lost obito so you can bet that kakashi
was traumatized when rin died by his
hand
and that traumatic event awakened his
mangekyo sharingan kakashi then passed
out
but what he didn't know was obito had
survived his wounds
and was actually watching as rin the
girl he loved
died his remaining shotgun like akashi's
evolved into a mangekyo shotgun and he
went on to kill
all the surrounding enemy ninja while
kakashi laid on the floor unconscious
not surprisingly kakashi was depressed
after all of this happened
he'd lost his mom and dad when he was
still young and then
as far as he knew obito died because of
him and not only did he fail to keep his
promise to obito by saving rin
she even died by his hand and yet after
all this suffering he somehow survived
without knowing why or how despite being
surrounded by countless enemy ninja
before he passed out
in the anime people even called him
friend killer kakashi
because they thought he purposely killed
rin so she wouldn't leak information
knowing how negative opinions influenced
his father we can assume that this kind
of talk didn't make akashi feel any
better
ironically once kakashi finally realized
the importance of prioritizing the lies
of his comrades people now started to
believe that he wouldn't hesitate to
kill a comrade for the sake of a mission
in the hopes that it would help with his
depression minato kakashi's old team
leader
and the new hokage had him join the anbu
and work directly under him
in the anime he was also assigned to
watch over kushina during her pregnancy
since the third and fourth
thought it might help him view life
differently it's cool to consider that
he was watching over his future pupil
naruto all this time
and during his off time he would visit
the graves of ren and obito during the
night tales attack as a younger shinobi
kakashi along with my guy kudanai and so
on
was kept away from the ninetails the
rationale was that since this was a
domestic problem
and not a war against the other villages
there was no need for the young
generation to risk their lives
this is a bit random since enemy village
or not the ninetales is still a threat
to the village and kakashi is clearly
more skilled and useful than many adult
ninja but to be fair
i don't think there is much he could
have done anyways since minato and
kushina made sure to take care of the
nighttails alone
even keeping the third from helping and
as we know minato and kushina died
during this battle which was yet another
blow to kakashi
not only were his teammates gone but now
his leader and teacher as well
not to mention his wife whom he watched
over during her pregnancy
minotau was clearly the closest person
he had left so you can't help but feel
bad for kakashi here
it was the perfect time for danzo to
take advantage of the grieving kakashi
and get him to join the foundation
although danzo briefly held some sway
over him and at some points it looked
like akashi might have betrayed the
third
this didn't last long kakashi actually
told hirozen
about one of donzo's plans to
assassinate him and help to thwart the
plans
the fact that hirose and forgave donzo
here is ridiculous to me but at least he
did recognize kakashi's potential and
made him his right hand man
in the anime after hirozen let
orochimaru escape kakashi confronted him
but was paralyzed by the killing intent
aka bloodthirst orochimaru was exuding
we saw sasuke similarly freeze up like
this against zabuza it's quite
remarkable that someone as skilled as
kakashi found himself in this position
and it goes to show the frightful power
of asanin danzo at one point
sent yamato then called kinoe after
kakashi to assassinate him and to bring
back his shotgun eye
kakashi ended up convincing the wood
release user and former orochimaru
experiment that their friendship was
more important than his mission and
eventually got the third hokage to take
yamato out of the foundation
once again hirosen failed to punish
danzo after the latter attempted to have
kakashi assassinated keep in mind this
is after he received a warning
after trying to assassinate hirozen
himself although i like hirozen you have
to admit that he was way too forgiving
especially if you take the anime only
moments into account
kakashi led team roh an elite anbu unit
serving directly under the hokage yamato
became part of this unit as did hitachi
for a time
hitachi eventually got promoted out of
the unit and when it got out that itachi
had murdered his clan kakashi unaware of
the entire truth thought
itachi truly had become a villain and
wished that he'd done a better job of
influencing him in the right direction
in the anime we then see hirozen take
akashi out of the unboo believing people
with kind hearts did not belong in the
organization he was eventually put in
charge of multiple teams
like team 7 but did not think that these
teams demonstrated the teamwork
necessary to pass
it goes to show how far kakashi had come
since the days that minoto used to have
to lecture
to him about the importance of teamwork
and finally that leads us to kakashi's
student and the seventh hokage
naruto uzumaki his backstory shouldn't
be too long since he is our protagonist
after all
and only a kid when our main story gets
started as we mentioned
naruto was born on the night of october
10th to kushina and minato the fourth
hokage
as we saw they named him after one of
jiraiya's characters and that made dry
his godfather so the bond between these
two was very strong and cemented even
before jaraya came to train him
on the night he was born he was at one
point taken hostage by obito
and then he was made to be the next nine
tails jin churyki as his parents
sacrificed their lives to save him
and the village quite a crazy first
night of existence
minotaur felt like naruto would need the
power of the nine tails down the line to
fight the powerful obito when he
returned one day
although he didn't know this mysterious
man was actually obito at the time even
from the first night minotaur was sure
that naruto
was the child of prophecy the chosen one
who would save the world from
catastrophe as we saw during minotaur's
backstory he split the ninetales power
in half
he placed the yang part in naruto and
the yin part within himself it was too
much power to all be
sealed in an infant but naruto would be
able to reunite with the yin part down
the line
and unlock kudama's full potential both
of naruto's parents died
but not before telling him how much they
loved him naruto lived as an orphan
and received monthly income from the
village to pay for his necessities
i feel like godfather jiraiya could have
stepped in to adopt him at some point
but hey he probably had a lot of
important things to do
including research naruto didn't know
who his parents were
or that his clan name was changed to his
mother's so he wouldn't be targeted by
his father's enemies
as mentioned before minato wanted people
to regard naruto
as the hero of the village after all by
taking the nine tales within himself
he saved the village from destruction
but that's not how people saw naruto at
all
minotau was way too hopeful for starters
people didn't know the full story like
that naruto was minato's son
furthermore they took all the hatred
that they had towards ninetales which
caused so much destruction and death in
the village
and directed it at naruto some even
equating naruto with the nine tails
this led to the orphan naruto being
ostracized and since hirozone felt bad
about that
he banned talk of the ninetails
altogether still the parents continued
to dislike naruto and it makes sense
that the effects of that would be passed
down to their children
even if the children didn't know the
complete truth behind those feelings
naruto growing up socially isolated and
lonely resorted to pulling pranks
because bad attention was better than no
attention
in the last naruto the movie we see how
naruto first met his future wife hinata
hyuga when he enrolled in the academy
he defended her from bullies who were
picking on her even at this early age he
was already saying he'd be the hokage
they beat him up but at least they did
leave hinata alone
in the end naruto led hinata keep his
red scarf that the bullies pretty much
ruined naruto didn't necessarily think
much of this incident standing up for
hinata despite not knowing her
was the right thing to do but for hinata
she pretty much fell in love with her
beat up savior right there
as she hugged his red scarf i will add
that down the line she will later
hand knit another red scarf for naruto
to replace this old one
and i find that detail to be incredibly
cute
but back to the academy where iruka
would become naruto sensei
and become the closest thing to a father
figure that naruto had up to that point
iruka may have hated the ninetales but
unlike the others he recognized naruto
as his own person
and wanted the best for him naruto also
wished to bond with sauce case since he
too was alone having lost his entire
clan however
as we all know sasuke is hard to
befriend and naruto ended up being
jealous of the uchiha child
because he was good at everything naruto
began to view him as a rival
wanting to be cool and strong like him
notably tauchi the owner of the ramen
restaurant in konoham
and his daughter ayame would welcome
naruto as their favorite customer
this may not seem like a big deal but
having people who welcome rather than
shunyu like everyone else in the village
no doubt meant a lot to the young and
lonely naruto
and that pretty much brings us to the
beginning of this epic tale that
is the naruto series so there it is
every hokage backstory aka what happened
to them before the main story began
this will probably be one of my longest
videos if not the longest so if you did
enjoy it
be sure to show your love by smashing
that like button until it changes colors
these videos take a bunch of time and
energy to make so like i said i would
really appreciate if you hit that like
button if we can hit
6 000 likes i repeat 6 000 likes
i'll get started on the next naruto
video asap just let me know
what topic you would like to see next in
the comments i personally
loved revisiting how these legends came
to be and i truly found their stories
inspiring and i hope you did as well if
you haven't be sure to subscribe and
this is crucial
hit that notification bell and select
all or you will miss future naruto
videos
and while you wait for your dream topic
to get covered feel free to check out my
growing naruto playlist which includes
videos on all the uzumaki all the
otsutsuki
all the kage and much more link to that
is in the description
and i especially want to thank the
patron squad over on patreon and here on
youtube who helped make videos like this
one possible
first and foremost i want to thank the
patrons of legend the ones acknowledged
by lord tuigo himself alpha sigma
and red-haired raven and are the
one-tier patrons the ones who stand on
top all clans ingrata pate hepa al-jatal
dr cortman the toasted chi ry carlo
emperor otaku spidey life tinel tungsten
tarkis and
cody hebert and our pro hero tier
patrons the one and only gilgamesh angel
cruz anatoly kozadski cricket xp
very gucci alicia actor bonnie parks
hinokami and water
ted no ted i sparky65 joey garcia fat
boy games
metal mama corey mcgowan deadly saints
soul ride slice and dice and
pill you thank you all so much if you do
enjoy our work you can support morbid by
going over to patreon.com
anime uproar and becoming a patron today
for as little as one dollar
if you do see a gear name featured in
future videos alongside these amazing
epic people right here and you'll even
get access to our private patron only
discord where we talk about the latest
chapters
the latest anime seasons life and of
course
thank memes so check out patreon.com
anime upload
link in the description if you're
interested you can also join the youtube
channel by clicking that blue join
button right next to the subscribe
button they've hopefully
already destroyed so yeah you can
support more content that way if you
prefer
whichever way you choose to support us
you can get the same
great benefits thanks again and until
next time
see ya space cowboys
[Music]
do
you